researchers have found out that polar
bears have higher metabolisms than
previously thought and are having
trouble eating enough food to keep up
their weight in the wild using GPS
enabled collars affixed with video
cameras researchers watched nine female
polar bears living in the Beaufort Sea
forage for food during three spring
seasons they also captured the Bears to
take blood and other samples at the
beginning and end of the study these
data in hand they measured how fast the
large carnivores burn calories and found
polar bears need to eat more than 12,000
calories per day minimum that means they
have to eat at least one adult ringed
seal with the equivalent of nearly 220
Big Macs every 10 to 12 days bears that
killed an eight ringed seals during the
eight to eleven day observation periods
gained or maintained weight but more
than half the Bears lost weight and four
lost at least ten percent of their body
weight it turns out polar bears use a
lot of energy when they walk more than
similarly sized animals
what's more the Bears they tracked
walked a fair amount more than a quarter
of the time this is bad news for these
bears a sea ice continues to collapse
energy demands may outstrip the Bears
ability to find food and ultimately lead
to their demise
[Music]
[Music]